today is rosh hashanah which means all
our jewish writers stayed home today
yeah so uh that's our show folks good
night
seriously seriously without those guys
you do not want it
they're good yeah they are very very
good no
i'm serious today is rosh hashanah which
means today's monologue was written
entirely by irish catholics
that's true yeah
yeah so do you want to hear an irish
catholic monologue joke all right here
we go
all right here we go yeah yeah before
mass last sunday
sister mary margaret spilled some coffee
on her sleeve
yeah i said hey sister between caffeine
and your outfit
you've got two bad habits
that's why
that's why i'm begging my jewish writers
please come back
that's the kind of crap you get from an
irish cowboy bag yeah
not good not good we do have some uh
some things to say in an interview
if you heard this former white house
press secretary sean spicer
said he never knowingly lied to the
american people
yeah yeah he then said damn it i just
lied again i can't help myself
it's a habit yeah
don't share that it's sad uh hey this
afternoon north korean leader kim
jong-un
lashed out at president trump called him
mentally deranged and a frightened dog
yeah yeah as a result kim jong-un is now
the democrat's top pick for president in
2020.
i think he has a chance i think he could
that was kind of a crazy moment right
there yeah terrible dictator
called our president a mangy dog and
people were like yay
we're in a weird time right now sure
just wanted to point that out
you